Londyn did it New York did it and now
San Francisco's doing it it's sort of
for a week the heart of the city is
going car-free turning into a
pedestrian's paradise one catch though
it's for the Super Bowl
and it's neat if you can reach it
traffic in San Francisco is already a
nightmare and now the big game is
bringing in a lot more people like a
million more people San Francisco says
it'll ease the horror with pedestrian
and cyclist detours extra subway service
and rerouted buses but we're not going
to take the city's word for it instead
we're gonna put them to the test
here's the game get from San Francisco
City Hall to Super Bowl City as fast as
possible the contestants public transit
car service and bike so normally San
Francisco run streetcars down this line
because everything is all screwed up
down by the Embarcadero they're running
buses instead I'm not entirely sure
where this goes actually it was headed
for Super Bowl City and at 225 a trip
it's almost a steal but it didn't take
us exactly where we wanted to go because
basically all of this is now dedicated
to Super Bowl City we stopped right here
at Main Street which means that if we
want to get the rest of the way we've
got to do it on foot bummer accessing
the fanfare by foot is tricky too with
only two access points and loads of
security which means it's time for round
two the San Francisco taxi so yeah Anu
burr
it's cushy but it's pricey about ten
times the cost of the bus it's slower to
over 25 minutes but it did drop us right
at Superbowl city's doorstep last
approach bikes we use the city's bike
share system 7 speed commuters available
all over downtown just 9 bucks for a
24-hour pass
but again unlike a real pedestrian
center Super Bowl City doesn't allow
bikes to get into or across it at least
a bike station was close to the entrance
of sports ball town I have to say the
bike is almost certainly the best way to
go the city could have mapped better
alternate routes that didn't include
some of San Francisco's more famous
Hills but overall this is the way to do
it Super Bowl City gives us a glimpse of
a future San Francisco where public
spaces are designed for people not just
cars but most pedestrian zones are
easily accessed and they don't place
four blocks of a major city on lockdown
the bottom line is if you want to create
a space like Super Bowl City that's
pedestrian friendly civic minded
altogether a nice place to be without
cars or buses getting in your way cities
need to more fundamentally rethink how
people move around